in deutschland leben viele menschen in
einer wg beginn steht für
wohngemeinschaft das bedeutet dass
menschen sich eine wohnung zusammen
teilen damit sie billiger leben kann
heute zeige ich euch das typische wg
leben und nehme ich einmal mit in einer
wg hat jeder sein eigenes schlafzimmer
manche wgs haben auch ein wohnzimmer wir
haben keins dafür treffen wir uns aber
immer in der küche und quatschen kochen
und essen zusammen es gibt kleinere wgs
und größere budgets kleinere wgs
bestehen zum beispiel aus zwei personen
größere können sogar aus fünf sechs
sieben oder acht personen bestehen wird
zum beispiel bestehen aus fünf personen
wir teilen uns ein gemeinschaftsbad
manchmal kommt es vor dass ein
mitbewohner von mir 50 minuten lang im
bad ist in einer wg teilt man sich
manche dinge zum beispiel lebensmittel
oder auch hygieneartikel
mein mitbewohner hat meine zahnpasta
leer gemacht jetzt muss ich eine neue
kaufen gehen
hier muss aber mal wieder geputzt werden
manche menschen leben zusammen nur weil
es billiger ist sie verbringen kaum zeit
miteinander
das nennt man zweck wg ich habe zum
beispiel zwei mitbewohner und zwei
mitbewohnerinnen zum glück verstehen wir
uns alle gut wir sind keine zweck wg es
passiert manchmal dass einer von meinen
mitbewohnern seinen schlüssel vergisst
mir ist das zum beispiel auch schon mal
passiert
manche wgs haben einen putzplan manchmal
funktioniert er und manchmal eben nicht
heute zum beispiel hat jemand von meinen
mitbewohnern vergessen den müll
rauszubringen
in berlin ist es besonders schwer eine
wg zu finden
manchmal wird nur ein zimmer frei für
ein paar monate
das nennt man dann zwischen miete in
einer wg hat jeder sein eigenes
kühlschrank fach wir schauen uns bei
unseren kühlschrank zusammen an das hier
ist zum beispiel mein kühlschrank fach
und wie ihr seht ist es leer
ich muss mal wieder einkaufen gehen es
kommt vor dass es in einer wg keine
spülmaschine gibt dann muss vor allen
dingen jeder darauf achten sein eigenes
geschirr zu spülen manche mögen's mehr
manche weniger
ich liebe pflanzen wenn ich in den
urlaub fahre dann frage ich meine
mitbewohner ob sie meine pflanzen gießen
kann manchmal kann es ganz schön
anstrengend sein in einer wg zu leben
das schöne ist aber dass man immer
jemand hat mit dem man reden kann lachen
kann quatschen kann essen kann und
trinken kann
manchmal wird man sogar zu einer echten
familie
wenn ihr jetzt noch lust habt deutsch zu
lernen dann probiert auf jeden fall
unsere apps ettling aus auf der ihr
interaktive übung ein vokabeltrainer und
viele nützliche geschichten für den
alltag finden werdet dank fürs zuschauen
und es bald ein wohnzimmer geschütztes
recht nicht sagen
manche wgs haben auch ein schlafzimmer
die sieben oder acht personen haben